Is it me or do you have a good ear? Maybe it's just an impression, but the song likes to relax the sound of people who talk to you about super captivating topics for hours. It sounds good, because I have something really interesting for you. The first mobility service by subscription to the country offered by the mobile audience. Yes, of course. At Star, you can subscribe to your 5G forfeiture without being attached. Mobile audience.
是我听错了吗，还是你的听力很好？也许这只是我的错觉，但那首歌似乎能让那些跟你聊了几个小时引人入胜话题的人放松下来。这听起来不错，因为我有一些非常有趣的事情要告诉你。这是移动用户提供的全国首个订阅制移动服务。是的，当然。在Star，你可以订阅你的5G套餐，而无需绑定。移动用户。
To you, the difference. Or on our website. Life in the waterfront city of Tampa, Florida was peaceful for 47-year-old Joanne Steffie. Her bungalow-style house backed onto a man-made canal that granted access to the sparkling blue waters of Tampa Bay. Small boats headed to and from the harbor pudded past Joanne's home, creating a relaxing coastal-like environment. Florida's warmth and sunshine added to the appealing atmosphere. In December 1988, a house for sale two doors down from Joanne's was purchased by a couple with a young daughter. In a street where residents knew one another and rarely moved, the new neighbors caused a stir.
对你来说，这就是区别。或者访问我们的网站。对于47岁的乔安妮·斯蒂菲来说，在佛罗里达州坦帕市滨水区的生活是宁静的。她的平房式住宅背靠一条人工运河，可以通往坦帕湾波光粼粼的蓝色水域。小型船只往返于港口，从乔安妮家门前缓缓驶过，营造出一种令人放松的海岸环境。佛罗里达的温暖和阳光增添了迷人的氛围。1988年12月，乔安妮家隔壁两栋的一处待售房屋被一对带着年幼女儿的夫妇买下。在一条居民彼此相识且很少搬家的街道上，新邻居引起了轰动。
While the woman and child were rarely seen, the man of the house was seemingly always outside. He was big and burly with a friendly and chatty disposition. He encouraged people to call him Obi after Obi-Wan Kenobi, a mentor-type character from the popular sci-fi film Star Wars. With his laid-back attitude, casual attire and blue and white powerboat, Obi fit right in. In time, the novelty of his family's arrival died down and they blended into the neighborhood. There was just one problem. Obi gave Joanne Steffie the creeps. She found his banter superficial and fake and he had a tendency to appear out of nowhere and insert himself into private conversations.
虽然很少见到那个女人和孩子，但家里的男人似乎总是在外面。他身材魁梧，性格友好健谈。他鼓励人们叫他“欧比”，取自流行科幻电影《星球大战》中导师型角色欧比旺·克诺比的名字。凭借他随和的态度、休闲的装束和蓝白相间的动力艇，欧比很快就融入了这里。随着时间的推移，他家人到来带来的新鲜感逐渐消退，他们融入了社区。只有一个问题。欧比让乔安妮·斯蒂菲感到毛骨悚然。她觉得他的谈吐肤浅且虚伪，而且他总喜欢突然出现并插话进入私人谈话中。
Joanne had also developed a hunch that he was hiding something. She aired her suspicions to another neighbor, but they considered Obi harmless. Nevertheless, Joanne took to avoiding Obi whenever possible. On a late Saturday night in early 1990, Joanne was in her kitchen when she glanced outside. A large figure was loitering in the glow of a streetlight close to Joanne's front door. It was Obi. He looked to be staring intently at Joanne's house. Joanne turned off the lights to give the impression she was going to bed, then positioned herself by a window.
乔安妮还产生了一种预感，觉得他在隐瞒什么。她向另一位邻居表达了怀疑，但他们认为欧比没有恶意。尽管如此，乔安妮还是尽可能地避开欧比。1990年初的一个深夜，乔安妮在厨房时向外瞥了一眼。一个高大的身影在乔安妮前门附近的路灯光下徘徊。是欧比。他似乎正全神贯注地盯着乔安妮的房子。乔安妮关掉灯，假装自己要睡觉，然后站在窗边。
She peered out. Obi remained put, his attention transfixed on Joanne's home. Five minutes ticked by before he finally moved as if awoken from a spell. He called out something and a little white dog ran up to his feet. Obi then wandered off in the direction of his home. Joanne's house was in the middle of the street. The Rogers family worked hard on their dairy farm in the small village of Wilshire, Ohio. 37-year-old patriarch Hal Rogers maintained the 300-acre property full-time.
她向外窥视。欧比依然站在那里，注意力集中在乔安妮的房子上。五分钟过去了，他终于动了，仿佛从咒语中惊醒。他喊了一声，一只小白狗跑到了他的脚边。随后，欧比朝着他家的方向走去。乔安妮的房子位于街道中间。罗杰斯一家在俄亥俄州威尔希尔小村庄的奶牛场辛勤工作。37岁的家长哈尔·罗杰斯全职打理着这片300英亩的土地。
Hal's 36-year-old wife Joanne, better known as Jo, helped out. Jo also worked nights as a forklift operator. Even the couple's two teenage daughters chipped in. 17-year-old Michelle and 14-year-old Christy Rogers juggled their schoolwork with farm chores. When it came time for the family to take a much needed break, they excitedly began planning a trip to Florida. The southern coast, with its hundreds of miles of beaches and festive atmosphere, offered a welcome change to the Rogers inland rural lifestyle. Importantly, Florida was the home of the Disney World theme park and resort.
哈尔36岁的妻子乔安妮（更广为人知的名字是乔）也帮忙。乔晚上还兼职做叉车司机。这对夫妇的两个十几岁的女儿也参与其中。17岁的米歇尔和14岁的克里斯蒂·罗杰斯在学校作业和农活之间忙碌。当全家人需要好好休息时，他们兴奋地开始计划去佛罗里达旅行。南部海岸拥有数百英里的海滩和节日氛围，为罗杰斯一家的内陆农村生活带来了受欢迎的改变。重要的是，佛罗里达是迪士尼世界主题公园和度假村的所在地。
While Hal and Jo had been on a few interstate trips throughout their long relationship, visiting Florida would mark the first time Michelle and Christy had left Ohio. Michelle eagerly crossed off each passing day on her calendar until her long-awaited holiday finally commenced on Friday, May 26, 1989. Hal wished he could go to Florida, but his farm needed constant upkeep, so he decided to stay home. At 1.30pm, he bid Jo, Michelle and Christy farewell. The women piled into the family car, a two-door blue ultimobile Calais. Jo drove down the dirt driveway headed for Interstate 75.
虽然哈尔和乔在他们长期的关系中去过几次州际旅行，但访问佛罗里达将是米歇尔和克里斯蒂第一次离开俄亥俄州。米歇尔急切地在日历上划掉每一天，直到她期待已久的假期终于在1989年5月26日星期五开始。哈尔希望他能去佛罗里达，但他的农场需要不断维护，所以他决定留在家里。下午1点30分，他向乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂告别。女人们挤进了家里的车，一辆双门蓝色奥兹莫比尔加莱。乔沿着土路车道驶向75号州际公路。
The highway would take them over 1,000 miles south through the streets of Kentucky, Tennessee and Georgia before reaching Florida. The trio would do back on Sunday June 4 at the latest as Jo had to work on Monday night. Days into their trip, Hal received a postcard from Florida's Central City, Orlando. It contained a message penned by Jo that read, Leaving for Disney World for three nights, weather is hot and humidity is very high. Kids having a great time dragging me everywhere. Better go, have to get Christy out of bed. Love you, take care.
这条高速公路将带她们向南行驶超过1000英里，穿过肯塔基州、田纳西州和佐治亚州的街道，然后到达佛罗里达。三人组最迟会在6月4日星期日回来，因为乔周一晚上要上班。旅行几天后，哈尔收到了一张来自佛罗里达中心城市奥兰多的明信片。上面有乔写的一条信息，写着：“去迪士尼世界待三天，天气很热，湿度很高。孩子们玩得很开心，到处拉着我。得走了，得把克里斯蒂从床上叫起来。爱你，保重。”
Don't work too hard. When Sunday June 4 arrived, Hal expected the ultimobile to pull up at any moment. Yet, the day wore on with no sign of his family. When Jo and the girls hadn't returned by nightfall, Hal began ringing around to see if someone else had heard from them. He discovered that Michelle had called her boyfriend three days earlier on Thursday June 1. The 10 minute call took place at around a lunchtime and had originated from a hotel room in the city of Tampa. Michelle had gushed to her boyfriend about how much fun she was having. The only bad thing she had to say was that she and Christy wanted to go into the ocean,
“别太辛苦了。”当6月4日星期日到来时，哈尔期待着奥兹莫比尔随时会停在门口。然而，一天过去了，仍不见家人的踪影。当乔和女儿们到天黑还没回来时，哈尔开始四处打电话，看看是否有人有她们的消息。他发现米歇尔在三天前的6月1日星期四给她的男朋友打过电话。那通10分钟的电话是在午餐时间左右打的，来自坦帕市的一家酒店房间。米歇尔向男朋友滔滔不绝地讲述她玩得有多开心。她唯一抱怨的是她和克里斯蒂想去海里玩，
but their mother wouldn't let them because they couldn't swim. Hal Rogers went to bed that night concerned, but told himself that Jo and the girls had probably just extended their holiday for another night. Perhaps they had found an interesting place to stay on the way home. Hal was certain they would reunite on Monday. Meanwhile, in Tampa, police were working diligently into the night following a disturbing discovery. Earlier that day, the Coast Guard had received a frantic radio call from a man on a sailboat in Tampa Bay. He had sighted something floating in the water and had moved in for a closer look. It was the lifeless body of a woman.
但她们的母亲不让，因为她们不会游泳。哈尔·罗杰斯那天晚上带着担忧上床睡觉，但告诉自己乔和女儿们可能只是把假期延长了一晚。也许她们在回家的路上找到了一个有趣的地方住。哈尔确信她们会在周一团聚。与此同时，在坦帕，警方在发现令人不安的情况后，彻夜勤奋工作。当天早些时候，海岸警卫队收到了一名坦帕湾帆船上男子的紧急无线电呼叫。他看到水里漂浮着东西，便靠近查看。那是一具女性的尸体。
Attempts to lift the body out of the water were hampered by a heavy object that was attached to the woman's neck via a thin yellow rope. After struggling to retrieve the body for 30 minutes, the Coast Guard had no choice but to cut the rope. The weight that anchored the body sank to the depths, allowing responders to lift the woman's body out with ease. She was naked from the waist down. Her ankles and wrists were hog-tired with rope. Duct tape had been placed over her mouth. Realizing the gravity of the situation, the Coast Guard alerted the police who organized to meet them at the shore. Within minutes of having retrieved this body, the Coast Guard received another emergency call.
试图将尸体从水中捞出的尝试因一根细黄绳系在女人脖子上的重物而受阻。在挣扎了30分钟试图打捞尸体后，海岸警卫队别无选择，只能切断绳子。锚定尸体的重物沉入深处，使救援人员能够轻松地将女人的尸体捞出。她腰部以下赤裸。她的脚踝和手腕被绳子紧紧捆住。嘴上贴着胶带。意识到情况的严重性，海岸警卫队通知了警方，警方安排在岸边与他们会合。在打捞出这具尸体几分钟后，海岸警卫队又接到了另一个紧急呼叫。
A second body had been spotted by a boat off four miles away. It was another woman. She was also partially naked, hog-tired, and gagged with duct tape. The victim had managed to free one of her hands and looked to have tried to remove the tape covering her mouth. There was also a thin yellow rope around her neck. It was tied to a heavy cinder block that responders were able to recover with the body. Just as the Coast Guard was travelling back to shore to meet with police, a third woman's body was found in the bay, two miles from the second. The victims presented the same way, making it clear that their murders were connected.
四英里外的一艘船发现了第二具尸体。那是另一名女性。她也部分赤裸，被紧紧捆绑，并用胶带封住嘴。受害者设法挣脱了一只手，看起来曾试图撕掉嘴上的胶带。她的脖子上也有一根细黄绳。它系在一块沉重的煤渣砖上，救援人员能够将其与尸体一起打捞上来。就在海岸警卫队返回岸边与警方会合时，在距离第二具尸体两英里处的海湾中发现了第三名女性的尸体。受害者的呈现方式相同，这清楚地表明她们的谋杀案是有关联的。
They had been in the water for about two days, which had expedited decomposition and washed away key evidence. The fact that all three were found naked from the waist down indicated that the crime was sexually motivated. Title analysis confirmed the women had entered the water from a boat, as they wouldn't have reached deep water in their condition from a bridge or the shoreline. The cinder blocks tied to their necks were a deliberate act to weigh their bodies down. None of the bodies had knife or bullet wounds or anything else to indicate a violent cause of death. This led a medical examiner to assume that they had entered the water while still alive. It could not be ascertained if the women had died from strangulation or drowning. Their official cause of death was listed as asphyxia.
她们在水中待了大约两天，这加速了腐烂并冲走了关键证据。三人腰部以下赤裸的事实表明犯罪具有性动机。尸检分析证实，这些女性是从船上进入水中的，因为她们在那种状态下无法从桥上或岸边到达深水区。系在她们脖子上的煤渣砖是故意用来压沉尸体的。尸体上没有刀伤、枪伤或其他表明暴力致死的迹象。这导致法医推测她们是在活着的时候进入水中的。无法确定这些女性是死于勒死还是溺水。她们的官方死因被列为窒息。
No identification was found with the victims. Their fingerprints were taken, but they didn't match any on record. Scouring Tampa Bay for evidence came up dry. When speaking to the press, authorities were up front. They had no motive, no suspects, and no leads. No one matching the victims' descriptions had been reported missing in the area recently. This led police to believe that the women were from elsewhere. Florida was a tourist hotspot, especially in the warmer months.
在受害者身上没有发现任何身份证明。提取了她们的指纹，但与记录中的任何指纹都不匹配。在坦帕湾搜寻证据一无所获。在接受媒体采访时，当局直言不讳。他们没有动机，没有嫌疑人，也没有线索。最近该地区没有报告任何符合受害者特征的失踪人员。这导致警方认为这些女性来自外地。佛罗里达是一个旅游热点，尤其是在温暖的月份。
A memo was sent to local hotel owners to be on the lookout for any female guests who had failed to check out. Four days after the bodies were discovered, a housekeeper was going about her workday. She was employed at the Days Inn, a hotel in the Bayside Tampa neighborhood of Rocky Point. She entered Room 251. The two double beds within were neatly made. Makeup and toiletries were on the bathroom counter, and clothing was scattered on the dark teal carpet. The hotel room had appeared exactly the same for the previous four days. The housekeeper informed her manager.
一份备忘录被发送给当地酒店业主，要求留意任何未退房的女性客人。尸体被发现四天后，一名客房清洁工正在进行日常工作。她在坦帕湾洛基角社区的戴斯酒店工作。她进入了251号房间。里面的两张双人床铺得整整齐齐。化妆品和洗漱用品放在浴室柜台上，衣服散落在深青色的地毯上。酒店房间在过去四天里看起来一模一样。清洁工通知了她的经理。
The guests assigned to Room 251 hadn't checked out yet. Their booking was under the name Rogers and applied to Joe Rogers and her two daughters, Michelle and Christie. They had checked into the room at midday on Thursday June 1 and hadn't been seen since. Homicide detectives were informed and arrived at the hotel room where they recovered Joe, Michelle and Christie's fingerprints. They were cross-checked with the three bodies found in nearby Tampa Bay. The missing women's dental records were also obtained to facilitate an ID check. There was absolutely no doubt. The three murdered women were Joe, Michelle and Christie Rogers. There were no signs of a struggle in the Rogers hotel room or anything else distinctly criminal.
分配到251号房间的客人还没有退房。她们的预订是以罗杰斯的名义，适用于乔·罗杰斯和她的两个女儿米歇尔和克里斯蒂。她们在6月1日星期四中午入住该房间，此后再未露面。凶杀案侦探接到通知并抵达酒店房间，在那里提取了乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂的指纹。这些指纹与在附近坦帕湾发现的三具尸体进行了交叉比对。还获得了失踪女性的牙科记录以协助身份核实。毫无疑问。三名被谋杀的女性正是乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂·罗杰斯。罗杰斯的酒店房间里没有打斗迹象，也没有其他明显的犯罪痕迹。
A role of camera film was taken into evidence and developed. The second last photo depicted Michelle Rogers sitting on the hotel room's floor. Although sunburned and weary, she did not appear distressed. The photo was taken the day the group had checked in. The final photo was taken from the hotel room's balcony of the sun sitting over Tampa Bay. This meant the three women had been in their hotel room at dusk on Thursday June 1. It was unknown where they had gone from there. Notably, the Rogers Blue Oldsmobile wasn't in the hotel parking lot.
一卷胶卷被作为证据带走并冲洗出来。倒数第二张照片显示米歇尔·罗杰斯坐在酒店房间的地板上。虽然晒伤且疲惫，但她看起来并不痛苦。这张照片是在她们入住当天拍摄的。最后一张照片是从酒店房间的阳台上拍摄的，太阳正落在坦帕湾上。这意味着这三名女性在6月1日星期四黄昏时分还在酒店房间里。此后她们去了哪里不得而知。值得注意的是，罗杰斯家的蓝色奥兹莫比尔不在酒店停车场。
The search for the car encompassed the nearby perimeter of Tampa Bay given its significance. It was soon discovered in a parking spot at a boat landing closest to the days in. There was nothing to suggest anything amiss had occurred in relation to the vehicle and only Joe, Michelle and Christie's fingerprints were found in and around it. The Oldsmobile contained a book of semi-complete crossword puzzles, a half-eaten chocolate bar, two decks of playing cards and a brochure with directions to the days in scribbled on it. There was also a piece of paper in the front that featured Joe Rogers handwriting. She had jotted down the directions to the boat ramp where her car was found and the words,
鉴于其重要性，对车辆的搜寻范围涵盖了坦帕湾附近的周边地区。它很快在距离戴斯酒店最近的一个船坞停车场被发现。没有任何迹象表明与该车辆有关的事情发生了异常，并且只在车内和周围发现了乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂的指纹。奥兹莫比尔里有一本半完成的填字游戏书、一块吃了一半的巧克力棒、两副扑克牌和一本上面潦草地写着去戴斯酒店路线的小册子。前面还有一张纸，上面有乔·罗杰斯的笔迹。她记下了去发现她汽车的船坡的路线，以及字样，
blue with white. Curiously, a blue and white-colored powerboat was sighted in the car park of the days in on the very day Joe and the girls went missing. The witness recalled the boat was being towed by a dark-colored car. This looked to be a promising lead. However, blue and white were common boat colors. Without anything to help detectives narrow in on this potential clue, it hit a dead end. In the initial stages of their investigation, detectives received close to 1,000 tips.
“蓝白相间”。奇怪的是，在乔和女儿们失踪的当天，有人在戴斯酒店的停车场看到了一艘蓝白相间的动力艇。目击者回忆说，这艘船是由一辆深色汽车拖着的。这看起来是一个有希望的线索。然而，蓝色和白色是常见的船只颜色。由于没有任何东西能帮助侦探缩小这个潜在线索的范围，它陷入了死胡同。在调查的初期阶段，侦探们收到了近1000条线索。
All were looked into, but none led to the killer or killers. One detective told the Cincinnati Post a newspaper that they were putting all their effort into the case because, quote, Everyone's been shocked by this, even among cops. You've got a whole family wiped out, practically. Back in Ohio, how Rogers was at a loss. Joe, Michelle and Christie were missing. He had initially convinced himself that they were held up sightseeing.
所有线索都进行了调查，但没有一条指向凶手或凶手们。一位侦探告诉《辛辛那提邮报》这份报纸，他们正在全力投入此案，因为，引用：“每个人都对此感到震惊，即使在警察中也是如此。你几乎失去了一整个家庭。”回到俄亥俄州，哈尔·罗杰斯不知所措。乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂失踪了。他最初说服自己她们是被观光耽搁了。
But once Joe skipped work, how knew something was wrong. He phoned the local police and highway patrol to inform them of the situation. At one stage, he was asked by police to provide his wife and children's dental records. He agreed, though wasn't quite sure why they were needed. By Friday, June 9, it had been 14 days since Hal had seen Joe and the girls. That day, an unfamiliar car rolled down his driveway. A man got out. He said he worked for a newspaper, then asked Hal for a comment on the drowning murders of Joe, Michelle and Christie.
但当乔错过工作时，哈尔知道出事了。他打电话给当地警察和公路巡警告知他们情况。在某个阶段，他被警方要求提供妻子和孩子的牙科记录。他同意了，虽然不太确定为什么需要这些。到6月9日星期五，距离哈尔见到乔和女儿们已经过去14天了。那天，一辆陌生的车开进了他的车道。一个男人走了出来。他说他在为一家报社工作，然后要求哈尔对乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂的溺水谋杀案发表评论。
It was the first Hal had heard of it. He spent the day carrying out his farm work in shock, not knowing what else to do. He blamed himself for what happened, believing that if he had gone on the Florida trip, then his wife and daughters would still be alive. A joint funeral service was held for Joe, Michelle and Christie Rogers. Over 300 Wilshire locals attended, a significant crowd considering the population wasn't much higher. Joe was remembered as a hard-working woman. Michelle was intelligent and modest. Christie was bubbly and sociable. As the Wilshire community grieved, homicide detectives arrived in town.
这是哈尔第一次听说这件事。他在震惊中度过了一天，继续做着农活，不知道还能做什么。他为发生的事情责怪自己，认为如果他去了佛罗里达旅行，那么他的妻子和女儿们现在还活着。乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂·罗杰斯举行了联合葬礼。超过300名威尔希尔当地人参加了葬礼，考虑到人口并没有多出多少，这是一个相当大的群体。乔被铭记为一个勤劳的女人。米歇尔聪明而谦虚。克里斯蒂活泼而善于交际。当威尔希尔社区哀悼时，凶杀案侦探抵达了镇上。
They had come to suspect that the answers they sought weren't in Florida, but closer to home. Just over a year before Joe, Michelle and Christie Rogers were killed, an 18-year-old woman presented to the emergency department of a hospital outside of Wilshire. For the sake of clarity, case file will refer to this woman as Zoe. Zoe was in a terrified state. She reported that she had been raped at Knife Point on the Rogers Dairy Farm. Zoe identified her attacker as her roommate, 31-year-old John Rogers. He co-owned the dairy business with his brother Hal. John and Zoe had been residing together in a trailer on site.
他们开始怀疑，他们寻找的答案不在佛罗里达，而是在离家更近的地方。在乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂·罗杰斯遇害前一年多，一名18岁的女子来到威尔希尔郊外的一家医院急诊科。为了清晰起见，案卷将这名女子称为佐伊。佐伊当时处于极度恐惧的状态。她报告说，她在罗杰斯奶牛场被持刀强奸。佐伊指认袭击者是她的室友，31岁的约翰·罗杰斯。他与兄弟哈尔共同经营这家奶牛场。约翰和佐伊一直住在现场的一辆拖车里。
As detailed in the Tampa Bay Times newspaper, John Rogers was known locally for being strange. He was an ex-marine with a muscular build and intimidating presence. He talked about missions he had allegedly undertaken for the Secret Service and Central Intelligence Agency, better known as the CIA. The content of these stories was enough to compel locals to keep their distance. Zoe lived with John out of necessity. She desperately needed a place to stay. Police arrived at the Rogers Farm to question John about Zoe's assault. As they spoke to John in his trailer, a detective noticed a briefcase on the floor of the living room area. John said the briefcase contained paperwork. He was asked to open it.
正如《坦帕湾时报》所详细报道的那样，约翰·罗杰斯在当地以古怪著称。他曾是一名海军陆战队员，身材魁梧，给人一种压迫感。他经常谈论他声称曾为特勤局和中央情报局（即中情局）执行过的任务。这些故事的内容足以让当地人对他敬而远之。佐伊出于无奈才与约翰住在一起。她迫切需要一个住处。警察来到罗杰斯农场就佐伊受袭一事盘问约翰。当他们在拖车里与约翰交谈时，一名侦探注意到客厅地板上有一个公文包。约翰说公文包里装的是文件。他被要求打开它。
John fiddled with the briefcase lock for a moment before saying that he had forgotten its combination. He was then handed a screwdriver and told to use it. The briefcase actually contained a videotape, five photographs and a cassette tape. The videotape featured footage of John sexually assaulting Zoe. The photographs depicted a different teenager altogether. She was naked, blindfolded and bound. The cassette tape was a recording of this young woman screaming for John Rogers to leave her alone. Detectives identified this second victim as John's niece, Michelle Rogers. Most of us have clothes we've loved for years, but it's harder than ever to find clothing that stands the test of time.
约翰摆弄了一会儿公文包的锁，然后说他忘记了密码。随后，他被递给一把螺丝刀，并被告知使用它。公文包里实际上装有一盘录像带、五张照片和一盘卡式录音带。录像带里有约翰性侵佐伊的画面。照片里是另一名完全不同的少女。她赤身裸体，被蒙住双眼并捆绑着。卡式录音带记录了这名年轻女子尖叫着让约翰·罗杰斯放过她的声音。侦探们确认这名受害者是约翰的侄女米歇尔·罗杰斯。我们大多数人都有穿了很多年的衣服，但现在要找到经得起时间考验的衣服比以往任何时候都难。
So for your summer closet update, shop American Giant. From hoodies and t-shirts to denim and more, you can build a wardrobe to be proud of for summers to come. Shop Lifetime Essentials at American-Giant.com and get 20% off with code LT23 at checkout. That's 20% off at American-Giant.com, promo code LT23. When police spoke to Michelle, she broke down. She revealed that her uncle John had been sexually abusing her for almost two years, beginning when Michelle was 14 years old. She kept word of the abuse secret, as John had repeatedly threatened to kill her if she spoke out. Hal and Joe Rogers had noticed their oldest daughter seemed nervous around John, but thought it was due to their clashing personalities.
因此，为了更新你的夏季衣橱，请选购American Giant。从连帽衫、T恤到牛仔裤等等，你可以打造一个让你在未来几个夏天都引以为傲的衣橱。在American-Giant.com选购终身必备单品，结账时使用代码LT23即可享受八折优惠。即在American-Giant.com使用促销代码LT23可享八折优惠。当警察与米歇尔交谈时，她崩溃了。她透露，她的叔叔约翰已经性虐待她近两年了，从米歇尔14岁时就开始了。她一直对虐待的事守口如瓶，因为约翰曾多次威胁说，如果她说出去就杀了她。哈尔和乔·罗杰斯注意到他们的大女儿在约翰面前显得很紧张，但以为这是因为他们性格不合。
Michelle protected her younger sister Christie by making sure she was never alone with their uncle. John was arrested in mid-February 1988 and was released on bail pending trial. Hal Rogers had put up the money that secured his brother's freedom, even though Hal's daughter was one of John's victims. Hal later explained that he had once given his word to John that he would get him out of jail no matter what. And Hal never broke promises. He did, however, make John sell his share of the dairy farm and told him never to come near his family again. The following year, John Rogers pleaded no contest for the rape of Zoe. To spare Michelle Rogers from having to testify, the charges pertaining to her assault were dropped.
米歇尔保护着她的妹妹克里斯蒂，确保她从不与叔叔单独相处。约翰于1988年2月中旬被捕，后保释候审。哈尔·罗杰斯支付了确保他兄弟获释的保释金，尽管哈尔的女儿也是约翰的受害者之一。哈尔后来解释说，他曾向约翰承诺，无论如何都会把他从监狱里救出来。而哈尔从不食言。不过，他确实让约翰卖掉了他在奶牛场的股份，并告诉他永远不要再靠近他的家人。次年，约翰·罗杰斯对强奸佐伊的指控表示不抗辩。为了免除米歇尔·罗杰斯出庭作证的痛苦，有关她受袭的指控被撤销了。
John ultimately received a 7-25 year sentence. A month after the trial, Michelle went to Florida with her mother and sister. It was hoped the change of scenery would help her move forward. She was resilient and determined to reclaim her life. John Rogers had been to Florida. He visited the state for a six-week holiday while on bail for his sex crimes. He went to many of the same locations that Joe, Michelle and Christie would come to visit a year later. John was in prison at the time of the triple homicide, leading detectives to wonder.
约翰最终被判处7至25年监禁。审判一个月后，米歇尔和她的母亲及姐妹去了佛罗里达州。人们希望换个环境能帮助她继续生活。她很坚强，决心重新掌控自己的人生。约翰·罗杰斯曾去过佛罗里达。他在因性犯罪被保释期间，曾去该州度假了六周。他去了许多乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂一年后会去的地方。三起谋杀案发生时，约翰正在监狱里，这让侦探们感到疑惑。
Had he made good on his previous threats to Michelle? Could he have made connections in Florida and organized a hit? Rumors were also circulating that John was involved in a drug and pornography ring. Apparently, Joe was aware, providing another motive why John would target the Rogers women. Yet, there was no way John could have known that Joe, Michelle or Christie were in Florida. He had no visitors in prison or correspondence with the outside world. John wasn't the only Rogers family member that raised suspicions. Gossip in Wilshire spotlighted Hal Rogers due to his perceived odd behavior in the aftermath of the murders of his wife and daughters.
他是否兑现了之前对米歇尔的威胁？他是否可能在佛罗里达建立了人脉并策划了一起雇凶杀人案？当时还有传言称约翰卷入了一个毒品和色情团伙。显然，乔对此有所察觉，这为约翰针对罗杰斯家女性提供了另一个动机。然而，约翰不可能知道乔、米歇尔或克里斯蒂在佛罗里达。他在狱中没有访客，也与外界没有任何通信。约翰并不是唯一一个引起怀疑的罗杰斯家族成员。威尔希尔的流言蜚语将矛头指向了哈尔·罗杰斯，因为他在妻子和女儿遇害后的行为被认为很古怪。
He didn't cry at their funeral and had taken to wearing tinted glasses. A feeling had arisen within the community that Hal was hiding something. Detectives checked Hal's bank records and discovered that he had withdrawn $7000 shortly after his family had gone missing. Hal explained that he had intended to use the money to drive to Florida and commence a search. He said he preferred to carry cash and that he kept the $7000 in his truck's glove compartment. Hal still had the money. But detectives were open to the possibility that it might have been intended as payment to someone involved in the murders. While Hal Rogers was enduring the suspicions of his local community, those who knew him well couldn't believe he was being considered a suspect.
他在葬礼上没有哭，还开始戴上有色眼镜。社区里产生了一种感觉，认为哈尔在隐瞒什么。侦探们检查了哈尔的银行记录，发现他在家人失踪后不久取走了7000美元。哈尔解释说，他打算用这笔钱开车去佛罗里达开始搜寻。他说他更喜欢携带现金，并把这7000美元放在卡车的杂物箱里。哈尔当时还有这笔钱。但侦探们不排除这笔钱可能是打算支付给参与谋杀案的人。尽管哈尔·罗杰斯承受着当地社区的怀疑，但那些了解他的人无法相信他会被列为嫌疑人。
The loss of his entire family had left him a shell of a man who buried himself in farm work as a distraction. Hal willingly took part in a polygraph test. While the results couldn't be used in any legal capacity, they led police to believe he absolutely wasn't involved in the murders. They came to view Hal as another victim in the case. The Rogers case was featured in the Florida Department of Law Enforcement Bulletin. The monthly publication was sent to police departments across the state. It detailed unsolved crimes to facilitate the sharing of information to help it generate leads. One Florida-based police officer was going through his paperwork four months after the killings when he came across the latest bulletin.
失去整个家庭让他变成了一个空壳，他埋头于农活中以分散注意力。哈尔自愿参加了测谎仪测试。虽然结果不能用于任何法律用途，但它们让警方相信他绝对没有参与谋杀。他们开始将哈尔视为案件中的另一名受害者。罗杰斯案被刊登在佛罗里达州执法部门的公告中。这份月刊被发送到全州的警察局。它详细介绍了未破案件，以促进信息共享，帮助产生线索。一名佛罗里达州的警官在谋杀案发生四个月后整理文书工作时，看到了最新的公告。
He was aware of the Rogers case due to its notoriety, but it was another unsolved crime that caught his eye. For the sake of clarity, case file will refer to the woman involved as Lucy. 24-year-old Lucy was originally from Ontario in Canada. She was visiting Florida on holiday in May 1989, two weeks before Joe, Michelle and Christie's trip. On the night of Sunday the 14th, Lucy had dinner with a female friend. The pair then walked to a nearby convenience store. It was around 9.30pm, and as the two women walked through the car park, they passed a relatively tall and heavy-set man. Despite having an imposing presence, he struck up a friendly conversation that put Lucy and her friend at ease.
他因罗杰斯案的知名度而了解该案，但另一桩未破案件引起了他的注意。为了清晰起见，案卷将涉案女子称为露西。24岁的露西来自加拿大安大略省。1989年5月，也就是乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂旅行前两周，她正在佛罗里达度假。14日星期日晚上，露西和一位女性朋友共进晚餐。两人随后步行到附近的一家便利店。当时大约是晚上9点30分，当两名女子穿过停车场时，她们经过了一名身材相对高大魁梧的男子。尽管他给人一种威严的感觉，但他主动展开了友好的交谈，让露西和她的朋友感到放松。
He introduced himself as Dave Posner. Dave warned the women to be careful, saying the crime rate in the area was high. He offered them a ride, so they wouldn't have to walk the dark and dangerous streets alone. Lucy and her friend accepted and got into Dave's dark-colored vehicle. It was a pleasant drive. At one stage, Lucy spoke of wanting to go fishing while in Florida. Dave told her that he had a powerboat and would be happy to take her out in Tampa Bay. Certain her friend would join them, Lucy made plans for the three of them to meet again the following day at 2pm.
他自称是戴夫·波斯纳。戴夫提醒这两名女子要小心，说该地区的犯罪率很高。他主动提出载她们一程，这样她们就不必独自走在黑暗危险的街道上。露西和她的朋友接受了邀请，上了戴夫那辆深色的车。这是一段愉快的车程。在某个阶段，露西提到想在佛罗里达期间去钓鱼。戴夫告诉她，他有一艘动力艇，很乐意带她去坦帕湾。露西确信她的朋友会加入她们，于是计划三人第二天下午2点再次见面。
However, Lucy's friend didn't want to go. She couldn't explain why exactly, but Dave gave her the creeps. Undeterred, Lucy went without her. She met Dave as planned, and the two headed out in his blue and white boat. The water was rough in the bay, so they didn't venture far. Dave appeared disappointed that Lucy's friend didn't join them, but was otherwise upbeat. He made easy conversation, talking about his family and mentioning his job as an aluminium salesman. Four hours after they had set off, Dave dropped Lucy back off at the pier.
然而，露西的朋友不想去。她无法确切解释原因，但戴夫让她感到毛骨悚然。露西没有被吓退，独自一人去了。她按计划见到了戴夫，两人乘着他的蓝白相间的船出发了。海湾里的水流很急，所以他们没有走远。戴夫似乎对露西的朋友没有加入感到失望，但除此之外他表现得很开朗。他谈笑风生，聊起自己的家庭，还提到自己是一名铝材推销员。出发四小时后，戴夫把露西送回了码头。
It was 6.30pm and the pair were about to go their separate ways when Dave had an idea. He said Tampa Bay was more beautiful at sunset and offered to take Lucy and her friend out on the water in an hour's time to experience it. Lucy walked back to where she was staying and let her friend know, but her friend still refused to be around creepy Dave. When Lucy returned to the pier alone, Dave became irritated and almost angry. He collected himself and helped Lucy back on his boat. As darkness fell, Dave steered his boat out to deeper waters. Other vessels disappeared from view and Lucy felt scared. She asked Dave to take her back to shore.
当时是下午6点30分，两人正准备分道扬镳，戴夫突然有了个主意。他说坦帕湾的日落更美，提议一小时后带露西和她的朋友出海欣赏。露西回到住处告诉了朋友，但朋友仍然拒绝接近那个令人毛骨悚然的戴夫。当露西独自回到码头时，戴夫变得烦躁，甚至有些愤怒。他平复了一下情绪，扶露西上了船。夜幕降临，戴夫将船驶向深水区。其他船只消失在视野中，露西感到害怕。她要求戴夫送她回岸上。
He refused and ordered her to sit on his lap. Lucy screamed. Dave responded bluntly. Do you think anyone will hear you? He then threatened to duct tape Lucy's mouth shut if she didn't stop. When he made his intentions to rape Lucy clear, she refused to give in. Is it really worth losing your life over? he asked. After raping Lucy, Dave vomited over the side of his boat.
他拒绝了，并命令她坐在他的腿上。露西尖叫起来。戴夫直截了当地回应道：“你以为会有人听见吗？”随后他威胁说，如果露西不闭嘴，就用胶带封住她的嘴。当他明确表示要强奸露西时，她拒绝屈服。他问：“为了这个丢掉性命真的值得吗？”强奸露西后，戴夫在船边呕吐了。
He then drove back to land, stopping every so often to vomit some more. When the boat reached shallow water, Lucy jumped out. Dave told her to watch her step, then drove away. Lucy reported the assault and helped facilitate a composite sketch of her assailant. The image depicted a boarding and weathered man in his late 30s with blue eyes, short reddish-brown hair and a mustache. Dave Posner managed to elude police, resulting in the publication of Lucy's case in the Florida Department of Law Enforcement Bulletin. Reading about Lucy's ordeal alongside the Rogers murders led one officer to notice the similarities between the two cases. A dark-colored vehicle was mentioned, as was a blue and white powerboat, duct tape, sexual assault.
随后他驾船返回陆地，途中不时停下来呕吐。当船到达浅水区时，露西跳了下去。戴夫叫她小心点，然后开车离开了。露西报了案，并协助绘制了袭击者的模拟画像。画像描绘了一名30多岁、皮肤黝黑、饱经风霜的男子，有着蓝色的眼睛、短红棕色头发和胡须。戴夫·波斯纳成功躲过了警察的追捕，导致露西的案件被刊登在佛罗里达州执法部门的公告中。一位警官在阅读露西的遭遇和罗杰斯谋杀案时，注意到了两起案件之间的相似之处。两案都提到了深色车辆、蓝白相间的动力艇、胶带和性侵犯。
All the women were tourists and had their clothing from the waist down removed. It was believed Joe and her daughters were lured into a boat in a manner similar to that of Lucy, hence why their car was at the ramp. A behavior analysis of the Rogers killer conducted by the FBI aligned with Dave Posner. They had described the killer as intelligent with good social skills. He was adept at making people feel at ease while presenting himself as a regular and hard-working, law-abiding citizen. His crimes would come as a surprise to those who knew him. Due to the killer's familiarity with the area and the fact he owned a boat, he most certainly lived in Tampa. The FBI believed Joe, Michelle and Christie were not his first victims and that he would strike again.
所有受害者都是游客，且腰部以下的衣物都被脱掉了。据信，乔和她的女儿们是以类似于露西的方式被诱骗上船的，这就是为什么她们的车会停在坡道上。联邦调查局对罗杰斯案凶手的行为分析与戴夫·波斯纳相吻合。他们将凶手描述为聪明且社交能力强的人。他善于让人们感到放松，同时表现得像一个普通、勤奋、守法的公民。他的罪行会让那些认识他的人感到震惊。由于凶手对该地区很熟悉，且拥有一艘船，他几乎肯定住在坦帕。联邦调查局认为，乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂并不是他的第一批受害者，而且他还会再次作案。
Locating Dave Posner became a high priority. Detectives weighed up the risk of tracking Dave down versus the chance he'd flee if he knew they were coming for him. The crimes were too significant to take a reserved approach, so officers decided to circulate the composite sketch of Dave in local newspapers in the hopes someone would recognize him. Saturday, November 4, 1989, was five months to the day Joe, Michelle and Christie Rogers left for their fateful trip to Florida. Tampa resident Joanne Steffi was sitting at her kitchen table reading the paper. The Rogers case was being spotlighted once again as a composite sketch of a possible suspect was now available. Joanne read about the case but had to set the paper aside upon realizing she was running late for an appointment. As she drove along her street, Joanne passed the home belonging to her creepy neighbor, locally known as Obi.
找到戴夫·波斯纳成了当务之急。侦探们权衡了追踪戴夫的风险与他得知消息后逃跑的可能性。这些罪行太严重了，不能采取保守的方法，因此警官们决定在当地报纸上发布戴夫的模拟画像，希望有人能认出他。1989年11月4日星期六，距离乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂·罗杰斯踏上前往佛罗里达的致命之旅正好五个月。坦帕居民乔安妮·斯特菲正坐在厨房桌旁看报纸。罗杰斯案再次成为焦点，因为现在有了嫌疑人的模拟画像。乔安妮读了关于此案的报道，但因为赶时间去赴约，不得不放下报纸。当她开车经过自己所在的街道时，经过了她那位令人毛骨悚然的邻居的家，当地人称他为“奥比”。
It suddenly dawned on her. Obi resembled the suspect sketch in the Rogers homicide case. She also drove a dark colored car and owned a blue and white power boat. Joanne clipped the suspect sketch out of the paper and showed it to her friend and fellow neighbor, a woman named Moselle. Moselle warned Joanne not to implicate Obi unless Joanne was absolutely certain of her theory. Joanne agreed and took the clipping home where she stuck it to her fridge. It remained there until early the following year when Joanne happened to spot Obi watching her house from the street one night. Scared of what Obi might have been capable of, Joanne spoke to a deputy sheriff who said he would look into it.
她突然意识到，奥比长得和罗杰斯谋杀案中的嫌疑人画像很像。他也开着一辆深色的车，并拥有一艘蓝白相间的动力艇。乔安妮从报纸上剪下嫌疑人画像，给她的朋友兼邻居莫塞尔看。莫塞尔警告乔安妮，除非有绝对把握，否则不要指控奥比。乔安妮同意了，把剪报带回家贴在冰箱上。直到第二年年初，乔安妮有一天晚上偶然发现奥比在街上盯着她的房子看，剪报才一直贴在那里。因为害怕奥比可能做出的事，乔安妮告诉了一位副警长，对方说会调查此事。
Joanne passed with no news, leading Joanne to assume authorities had investigated Obi and cleared him of any involvement in the Rogers case. Two years passed without any breakthroughs. In October 1991, a Florida-based police sergeant named Glenn Moore joined the team investigating the Rogers case. It was hoped a fresh pair of eyes might uncover something previously missed. Moore and the team went over all the information they had. Their attention soon turned to a brochure that was found in the Rogers family car. It was for Clearwater Beach, a popular coastal resort about 15 miles from Tampa. The brochure was found to have originated from a tourist stop near the Georgia-Florida border.
乔安妮一直没有收到消息，这让她以为当局已经调查了奥比并排除了他与罗杰斯案的任何关联。两年过去了，没有任何突破。1991年10月，一位名叫格伦·摩尔的佛罗里达州警长加入了罗杰斯案的调查组。人们希望换个角度看问题可能会发现之前遗漏的东西。摩尔和团队重新梳理了所有信息。他们的注意力很快转向了在罗杰斯家车里发现的一本小册子。那是关于克利尔沃特海滩的，这是一个距离坦帕约15英里的热门沿海度假胜地。这本小册子被发现源自佐治亚州和佛罗里达州边界附近的一个旅游站点。
Anyone linked to the brochure and distribution had already been questioned and cleared. The brochure featured handwritten directions to the Rogers Tampa-based hotel. Whoever scrawled them had a very distinct writing style. They put capital letters among the lower case and their letter Y had a uniquely long tail. This peaked Sergeant Moore's interest. The handwriting did not match Jo's, Michelle's or Christie's. Sergeant Moore pondered the likelihood that Joanne and the girls got lost en route to the days in and had asked someone for directions. The brochure was checked for prints revealing a partial palm print that didn't belong to any of the three Rogers women.
任何与这本小册子及其分发有关的人都已接受过询问并被排除嫌疑。小册子上写着手写的去往罗杰斯在坦帕入住酒店的路线。写下这些字的人笔迹非常独特。他们在小写字母中夹杂了大写字母，而且字母“Y”的尾巴特别长。这引起了摩尔警长的兴趣。笔迹与乔、米歇尔或克里斯蒂的都不符。摩尔警长推测，乔安妮和女孩们在去酒店的路上迷路了，并向某人问路。小册子经过指纹检查，发现了一个不属于三名罗杰斯女性中任何一人的部分掌纹。
Sergeant Moore came up with a novel idea. He had the handwriting from the brochure printed in newspapers and posted on billboards in the Tampa area. It was accompanied with the message. Who wrote these directions? You may know who killed the Rogers family. A $25,000 reward was also on offer as an added incentive. Joanne Steffie saw the handwriting sample in the local paper and took it to her friend, Moselle. Moselle had been listening to Joanne's worries about their neighbour, Obie, for some time.
摩尔警长想出了一个新颖的主意。他将小册子上的笔迹印在报纸上，并张贴在坦帕地区的广告牌上。随附的信息是：“谁写了这些路线？你可能知道是谁杀害了罗杰斯一家。”作为额外的激励，还提供了2.5万美元的悬赏。乔安妮·斯特菲在当地报纸上看到了笔迹样本，并把它拿给朋友莫塞尔看。莫塞尔已经听乔安妮倾诉关于邻居奥比的担忧有一段时间了。
Obie was an aluminium salesman who had previously provided Moselle with a quote for work she wanted done to her front porch. He had written out an estimate and given her a carbon copy. Moselle searched for hours and eventually found the estimate buried among paperwork. She and Joanne compared it to the sample in the newspaper article. It was an exact match. Joanne mailed and faxed it to the local police headquarters. She then waited to hear on the news that Obie, whose real name was Oba Chandler, had been arrested in relation to the Rogers triple homicide. She heard nothing.
奥比是一名铝材推销员，曾为莫塞尔想要做的前廊工程提供过报价。他写了一份估价单，并给了她一份复写件。莫塞尔找了几个小时，终于在文件堆中找到了那份估价单。她和乔安妮将其与报纸文章中的样本进行了对比。完全吻合。乔安妮将其邮寄并传真给了当地警察总部。然后她等待着在新闻中听到奥比（真名奥巴·钱德勒）因涉及罗杰斯三尸命案而被捕的消息。但她什么也没听到。
Joanne made several follow-up calls to find out if the police could analyse the handwriting samples she had sent. She was told that the case investigators were making their way through a large amount of leads and that hers would be examined in time. June passed and by late July, Joanne was still awaiting contact from authorities. Frustrated by their lack of action, Moselle's adult daughter faxed the handwriting samples through to police again. Her accompanying message read, Here is another copy of Oba Chandler's handwriting. Many of us are convinced that his handwriting is the one published in the papers. We feel so strongly that they are one and the same that due to your lack of response, we were tempted to pursue this with a handwriting expert of our own.
乔安妮打了几个后续电话，询问警方是否可以分析她寄去的笔迹样本。她被告知案件调查人员正在处理大量线索，她的样本会及时进行检查。六月过去了，到了七月下旬，乔安妮仍在等待当局的联系。由于对他们的不作为感到沮丧，莫塞尔的成年女儿再次将笔迹样本传真给了警方。随附的信息写道：“这是奥巴·钱德勒笔迹的另一份副本。我们许多人都确信他的笔迹就是报纸上公布的那一份。我们非常确信它们是同一个人所写，由于你们一直没有回应，我们打算找我们自己的笔迹专家来处理这件事。”
Following this, investigators were willing to take on the concerns of Joanne's Steffi and her neighbours. Within three days, a handwriting expert confirmed that the directions on the Clearwater Beach brochure were indeed penned by Oba Chandler. It was such a close match, it was regarded as unmistakable. While this only proved that Chandler had given the Rogers women directions, it established that he had direct contact with them in the lead-up to their murders. And he knew where they were staying. Yet, by the time police closed in on Oba Chandler, they were too late. He was long gone. Oba Chandler was born in Ohio, the only son in a family of five children.
此后，调查人员愿意接受乔安妮的斯蒂芬妮及其邻居们的担忧。三天内，一位笔迹专家证实，清水海滩宣传册上的方向指引确实是奥巴·钱德勒亲笔所写。由于匹配度极高，这被认为是无可辩驳的。虽然这仅证明了钱德勒曾为罗杰斯一家指路，但它确立了他在她们遇害前与她们有过直接接触的事实。而且他知道她们住在哪里。然而，当警方锁定奥巴·钱德勒时，已经太晚了。他早已逃之夭夭。奥巴·钱德勒出生于俄亥俄州，是家中五个孩子里唯一的儿子。
His father was a strict disciplinarian who took his own life. The death marked a turning point in 10-year-old Oba Chandler. The once quiet and intelligent boy became disruptive. This carried on into his adult years, during which Chandler served short stints in jail for armed robbery, drug dealing and counterfeiting. While committing a home invasion, Chandler forced the female resident to undress before restraining her to a bed. On another occasion, he bound a woman's hands and feet and covered her mouth in duct tape. By May 1988, Chandler was in the midst of his third marriage. He had eight children with multiple women.
他的父亲是一位严厉的管教者，后来选择了自杀。这次死亡标志着10岁的奥巴·钱德勒人生的转折点。曾经安静聪明的男孩变得具有破坏性。这种行为一直持续到他成年，期间钱德勒因武装抢劫、贩毒和伪造货币多次入狱。在一次入室抢劫中，钱德勒强迫女住户脱光衣服，然后将她捆绑在床上。另一次，他捆绑了一名女性的手脚，并用胶带封住了她的嘴。到1988年5月，钱德勒正处于他的第三段婚姻中。他与多名女性育有八个孩子。
Chandler purchased a small bungalow-style home in Tampa. His blue and white powerboat was docked at the pier connected to his property and he parked his dark-colored Jeep Cherokee in the driveway. Oba Chandler worked hard to build a good rapport with his neighbors. Then, in June 1990, he surprised them all by suddenly moving away without telling anyone. It was a year into the Rogers Homicide Investigation and shortly after a composite sketch of the suspect was widely publicised. The investigation into Oba Chandler was given the codename The Tin Man, in reference to Chandler's work as an aluminium salesman. Detectives flew to Ontario in Canada where they spoke with Lucy, the woman who was raped aboard a boat by Dave Posner in May 1989. Upon viewing a photo lineup, Lucy pointed out Oba Chandler as being Dave Posner.
钱德勒在坦帕买了一栋小型平房。他的蓝白相间动力艇停泊在自家房产相连的码头上，他将深色的吉普切诺基停在车道上。奥巴·钱德勒努力与邻居建立良好的关系。然而，1990年6月，他突然搬走，没有告诉任何人，这让所有人都感到惊讶。当时罗杰斯谋杀案调查已经进行了一年，就在嫌疑人的合成素描被广泛公布后不久。针对奥巴·钱德勒的调查代号为“锡人”，这是指钱德勒作为铝材推销员的工作。侦探们飞往加拿大安大略省，与露西交谈，她曾于1989年5月在船上被戴夫·波斯纳强奸。在查看照片排查时，露西指认奥巴·钱德勒就是戴夫·波斯纳。
The friend who had been travelling with Lucy at the time made the same identification. Chandler's resemblance to the composite sketch of Lucy's rapist was uncanny. Oba Chandler was tracked almost 300 miles from Tampa. He had resettled on the other side of the state in the seaside city of Daytona Beach. On Thursday, September 24, 1992, Chandler was visiting pawn shops trying to offload $750,000 worth of jewellery he had stolen. When he pulled into a gas station, officers swooped and he was placed under arrest for sexual battery. Word of his arrest spread, along with rumours that he was involved in the murders of Joe, Michelle and Christie Rogers. The news left his current neighbours in Daytona Beach stunned.
当时与露西同行的朋友也做出了同样的指认。钱德勒与露西强奸案嫌疑人的合成素描长得惊人地相似。奥巴·钱德勒在距离坦帕近300英里外的地方被追踪到。他已搬到州另一侧的海滨城市代托纳比奇重新定居。1992年9月24日星期四，钱德勒正在当铺试图脱手他偷来的价值75万美元的珠宝。当他驶入加油站时，警察一拥而上，他因性侵罪被捕。他被捕的消息传开了，同时还有传言称他卷入了乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂·罗杰斯的谋杀案。这个消息让他在代托纳比奇的现任邻居们感到震惊。
He seemed like a normal guy, one neighbour told the Tampa Times newspaper. With Oba Chandler behind bars, detectives worked to see if they could implicate him in the Rogers triple homicide. They were able to recover Chandler's old blue and white powerboat, which he had sold three months after the murders. So much time had passed, nothing of significance was uncovered. Yet, one of Chandler's sisters recalled him collecting newspaper clippings about the Rogers case. When she confronted him about it, he allegedly confessed to the killings, before saying, I'm just bullshitting. On another occasion, Chandler allegedly told one of his daughters that he couldn't go back to Florida because, quote,
“他看起来像个正常人，”一位邻居告诉《坦帕时报》。随着奥巴·钱德勒入狱，侦探们努力寻找证据，看能否将他与罗杰斯三尸命案联系起来。他们成功找回了钱德勒那艘旧的蓝白动力艇，他在谋杀案发生三个月后将其卖掉。由于时间过去太久，没有发现任何有价值的线索。然而，钱德勒的一位姐妹回忆说，他曾收集关于罗杰斯案的剪报。当她就此事质问他时，据称他承认了杀人，随后又说：“我只是在胡说八道。”另一次，钱德勒据称告诉他的一个女儿，他不能回佛罗里达，因为，引用：
the police are looking for me because I killed some women. Chandler had also allegedly confessed to his son-in-law, saying he threw at least one woman overboard. The evidence against Oba Chandler was circumstantial, though it was enough for a grand jury to indict him to stand trial for the murders of Joe, Michelle and Christie Rogers in addition to his crimes against Lucy. Chandler rented her not guilty plea. The trial commenced in September 1994. Oba Chandler appeared in court wearing a casual shirt and khaki pants and flashing a broad smile. He was impassive throughout proceedings, but would become jovial with his defense team during breaks.
“警察在找我，因为我杀了一些女人。”据称钱德勒还向他的女婿坦白，说他至少把一个女人扔进了海里。针对奥巴·钱德勒的证据是间接的，但足以让大陪审团起诉他，就乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂·罗杰斯的谋杀案以及针对露西的罪行进行审判。钱德勒拒不认罪。审判于1994年9月开始。奥巴·钱德勒出庭时穿着休闲衬衫和卡其裤，脸上挂着灿烂的笑容。他在整个诉讼过程中面无表情，但在休息期间会与辩护团队谈笑风生。
The prosecution relied on similar fact evidence in the rape case of Canadian tourist Lucy to show that both crimes were linked. The assistant state attorney argued that the boat was the perfect place for Chandler to commit his crimes, saying, It could be committed in darkness and without the possibility of escape. Chandler's defense team put forth that acts between their client and Lucy were consensual. While they admitted that things got out of hand in that instance, they stressed that this didn't mean their client was a triple murderer. He didn't do it. It's that simple they maintained. They painted Chandler as a helpful man who had only offered the Rogers women directions. That simple act of kindness had now spiralled into wild and baseless accusations.
检方在加拿大游客露西的强奸案中依赖类似事实证据，以证明两起罪行有关联。助理州检察官辩称，船是钱德勒犯罪的完美场所，他说：“这可以在黑暗中进行，且没有逃脱的可能性。”钱德勒的辩护团队提出，他们当事人与露西之间的行为是双方自愿的。虽然他们承认在那次事件中事情失控了，但他们强调这并不意味着他们的当事人是三尸命案的凶手。“他没做过。就这么简单，”他们坚持道。他们将钱德勒描绘成一个乐于助人的人，只是为罗杰斯一家指了路。那种简单的善举现在演变成了疯狂且毫无根据的指控。
Three men who spent time remanded with Oba Chandler were called to testify. One said that Chandler had told him the only reason he hadn't killed the Canadian tourist was because her friend back on shore would recognize him. Another testified that Chandler had told him that his biggest mistake was leaving the note in the car. Chandler had allegedly told another inmate that the last words he spoke to the Rogers women before throwing them overboard was to, quote, Swim for it. When it was looking likely that the jury would not find in Oba Chandler's favor, the defense threw a curveball. They argued that the sexual battery charge should be dropped as Lucy couldn't pinpoint exactly where the alleged rape had taken place. If it occurred more than nine nautical miles off the coast, it was outside of US jurisdiction.
三名曾与奥巴·钱德勒一起被拘留的男子被传唤作证。其中一人说，钱德勒告诉他，他没有杀害那名加拿大游客的唯一原因，是因为她在岸上的朋友会认出他。另一人作证说，钱德勒告诉他，他最大的错误是在车里留下了那张纸条。据称钱德勒告诉另一名囚犯，他在把罗杰斯一家扔进海里前说的最后一句话是，引用：“游回去吧。”当陪审团看起来不太可能做出对奥巴·钱德勒有利的裁决时，辩方抛出了一个杀手锏。他们辩称，性侵指控应该撤销，因为露西无法准确指出所谓的强奸发生在何处。如果发生在离岸九海里以外，那就超出了美国的司法管辖范围。
This meant the prosecution would also lose their similar fact evidence tying Lucy's case to the Rogers. In response, the prosecution reiterated key details in Lucy's statement. Specifically, she saw people on the shore and heard a bell ringing from the mainland. This meant Chandler's boat must have been only around a mile offshore. The defense then sought to implicate John Rogers in the murders, given his previous sex offences against his niece Michelle Rogers. The defense floated the long since disregarded hitman theory to explain how John could pull off the crimes. This prompted the judge to respond, You are not getting into John Rogers. John Rogers is a red herring. That is a moot issue.
这意味着检方也将失去将露西案与罗杰斯案联系起来的类似事实证据。作为回应，检方重申了露西陈述中的关键细节。具体来说，她看到了岸上有人，并听到了来自大陆的钟声。这意味着钱德勒的船一定离岸只有一英里左右。辩方随后试图将约翰·罗杰斯牵连进谋杀案，鉴于他之前对侄女米歇尔·罗杰斯的性犯罪记录。辩方提出了早已被忽视的“职业杀手理论”来解释约翰如何能犯下这些罪行。这促使法官回应道：“你们不要扯到约翰·罗杰斯身上。约翰·罗杰斯是个干扰项。那是个无关紧要的问题。”
The executive assistant state attorney labelled the hitman theory as idiotic. Ober Chandler took the stand in his own defense. But when asked about his involvement in the rape of Lucy, he pleaded the fifth. The right to avoid answering questions in court when the answers may self incriminate. He then snapped that it had nothing to do with Rogers' case. Records showed that Chandler had made three phone calls from his boat between 1 and 2 am the night of the murders. He made another two shortly before 10 am. Chandler testified that he had been out fishing and wound up stranded overnight because his boat's fuel tank sprung a leak and emptied.
执行助理州检察官称“职业杀手理论”是愚蠢的。奥巴·钱德勒为自己的辩护出庭作证。但当被问及他是否参与强奸露西时，他援引了第五修正案。这是在法庭上避免回答可能导致自我定罪问题的权利。他随后厉声说这与罗杰斯案无关。记录显示，在谋杀案发生的当晚凌晨1点到2点之间，钱德勒从他的船上打了三个电话。他在上午10点前又打了两个。钱德勒作证说，他当时出海钓鱼，因为船的油箱漏油排空，导致他被困过夜。
He flagged down a Coast Guard vessel the following morning, but they were unable to assist as they were en route to an urgent job. Another boat eventually towed Chandler to shore. A member of the Tampa Bay Coast Guard told the court that none of their vessels were in the bay at the time Chandler asserted. Logbooks confirmed that they hadn't been called to any jobs that morning. Furthermore, a marine patrol expert established that Chandler's boat couldn't have leaked all of its fuel. An anti-siphon valve prevented this from happening. When the prosecution asked if he had killed the Rogers family, Chandler responded, I have never killed no one in my whole life. It's ludicrous. It's ridiculous.
他第二天早上向一艘海岸警卫队的船只求助，但他们无法提供帮助，因为他们正在执行紧急任务。另一艘船最终将钱德勒拖回岸边。坦帕湾海岸警卫队的一名成员告诉法庭，钱德勒所说的时间段内，他们没有任何船只在海湾。航海日志证实，那天早上他们没有接到任何任务。此外，一名海洋巡逻专家确定，钱德勒的船不可能漏光所有燃油。防虹吸阀阻止了这种情况发生。当检方问他是否杀害了罗杰斯一家时，钱德勒回答：“我这辈子从来没杀过人。这太荒谬了。这太可笑了。”
The jury only needed five minutes to reach their unanimous verdict. For the first degree murders of Joe, Michelle and Christie Rogers, Ober Chandler was found guilty. Given this result, the lesser sexual battery charge against him was dropped. During sentencing, the presiding judge said, One victim was first, two watched. Imagine the fear. One victim was second, one watched. Imagine the horror. Finally, the last victim, who had seen the other two disappear over the side, was lifted up and thrown overboard. Imagine the terror.
陪审团仅用了五分钟就达成了全体一致的裁决。对于乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂·罗杰斯的一级谋杀罪，奥巴·钱德勒被判有罪。鉴于此结果，针对他的较轻的性侵指控被撤销。在量刑期间，主审法官说：“一名受害者先被杀，两人看着。想象一下那种恐惧。第二名受害者被杀，一人看着。想象一下那种惊恐。最后，最后一名受害者，在目睹了另外两人消失在船边后，被举起并扔进海里。想象一下那种恐怖。”
Ober Chandler, you have not only forfeited your right to live among us, but under the laws of the state of Florida, you have forfeited your right to live at all. May God have mercy on your soul. Ober Chandler was sentenced to death. A juror later told the Tampa Bay Times, He had a smirk. I just wanted to walk over there and slap it off his face. During his 17 years on death row, Ober Chandler never expressed remorse for his crimes. No one visited him in prison and attempts to appeal his verdict failed. He was put to death by lethal injection in November 2011.
“奥巴·钱德勒，你不仅丧失了与我们共同生活的权利，而且根据佛罗里达州的法律，你已经丧失了生存的权利。愿上帝怜悯你的灵魂。”奥巴·钱德勒被判处死刑。一位陪审员后来告诉《坦帕湾时报》：“他当时露出了那种假笑。我真想走过去把它从他脸上扇掉。”在死囚牢房的17年里，奥巴·钱德勒从未对自己的罪行表示悔恨。没有人去监狱探望他，他上诉判决的尝试也均告失败。他于2011年11月被执行注射死刑。
He was 64 years old. In late 1990, 20-year-old Ivalice Berrios Begaris was working at a sports store in the city of Coral Springs, Florida. On the evening of Monday, November 26, Ivalice finished a shift and left the mall where her store was located with several of her coworkers. It was just after 10pm when the group farewelled each other in the parking lot. Ivalice then headed off to her car alone. When Ivalice failed to return home, her husband headed to the shopping mall. He spotted Ivalice's car in the nearly empty lot. She was nowhere to be found. The two tires on the passenger side of Ivalice's car were found to have been slashed.
他当时64岁。1990年底，20岁的伊瓦莉丝·贝里奥斯·贝加里斯在佛罗里达州科勒尔斯普林斯市的一家体育用品店工作。11月26日星期一晚上，伊瓦莉丝下班后与几位同事离开了她所在的商场。刚过晚上10点，一行人在停车场道别。随后，伊瓦莉丝独自走向她的车。当伊瓦莉丝没有回家时，她的丈夫前往商场。他在几乎空无一人的停车场发现了伊瓦莉丝的车。她不见踪影。伊瓦莉丝车子乘客侧的两条轮胎被发现被割破了。
Three hours later, Ivalice's body was found lying naked under the letterbox of a residential house approximately two and a half miles from the mall. She had been strangled to death. Her wrists and ankles featured a ligature marks and there was brown packing tape stuck in her hair. An extensive investigation failed to uncover Ivalice's killer and her case went cold. Ivalice's body had been swabbed for traces of foreign DNA, but it took 23 years before forensic testing had reached the point where anything significant could be uncovered from the samples. In 2013, cold case detectives had the swabs reexamined using advanced techniques. DNA was lifted from traces of semen. They matched an existing profile on the state's criminal database.
三小时后，伊瓦莉丝的尸体被发现赤裸地躺在距离商场约2.5英里的一处住宅的信箱下。她被勒死。她的手腕和脚踝上有勒痕，头发里粘着棕色的包装胶带。大规模的调查未能发现伊瓦莉丝的凶手，她的案件成了悬案。伊瓦莉丝的尸体曾被采集过外源DNA痕迹，但直到23年后，法医检测技术才发展到能从样本中发现重要线索的程度。2013年，悬案侦探使用先进技术重新检查了拭子。从精液痕迹中提取了DNA。它们与州犯罪数据库中现有的档案相匹配。
Ivalice Berrios Begaris's killer was over Chandler. At the time of Ivalice's murder, Chandler lived less than two miles from the mall where she worked. Chandler abruptly moved away days after the slain. He was in such a haste he left all his furniture behind. One of the detectives fronting Ivalice's cold case told CBS News, It was a case that people were very afraid of and now finding out years later who the suspect was. They had every right to be afraid. By the time over Chandler was identified as Ivalice's killer, he had been dead for three years.
伊瓦莉丝·贝里奥斯·贝加里斯的凶手是奥巴·钱德勒。在伊瓦莉丝遇害时，钱德勒住在离她工作商场不到两英里的地方。钱德勒在凶案发生几天后突然搬走。他走得如此匆忙，以至于留下了所有的家具。负责伊瓦莉丝悬案的一名侦探告诉哥伦比亚广播公司新闻：“这是一个让人们非常恐惧的案件，多年后才发现嫌疑人是谁。他们有充分的理由感到恐惧。”当奥巴·钱德勒被确认为伊瓦莉丝的凶手时，他已经死了三年了。
If not for Chandler's execution, authorities have said that he would have been charged with Ivalice's murder. Ivalice Berrios Begaris was murdered one and a half years after Joe, Michelle and Christie Rogers. He had indeed struck again. Hal Rogers struggled in the years following his family's murders. As detailed in the Pulitzer Prize winning article Angels and Demons by Thomas Franch, Hal couldn't bring himself to clear his home of Joe, Michelle and Christie's belongings. He kept their rooms the same as when they had left for Florida. For a time he lived in denial, often speaking about his wife and daughters in present tense while believing they would come home at any time.
如果不是因为钱德勒被处决，当局表示他本会被指控谋杀伊瓦莉丝。伊瓦莉丝·贝里奥斯·贝加里斯是在乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂·罗杰斯遇害一年半后被谋杀的。他确实再次作案了。哈尔·罗杰斯在家人遇害后的几年里生活得很艰难。正如托马斯·弗兰奇在普利策奖获奖文章《天使与恶魔》中所详述的那样，哈尔无法让自己清理家中乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂的遗物。他保持着她们的房间原样，就像她们去佛罗里达时一样。有一段时间，他生活在否认现实中，经常用现在时谈论他的妻子和女儿，相信她们随时会回家。
At one point Hal drove to the cemetery with a shovel intending to dig up their graves, just so he could confirm they were really in there. He reached the cemetery, only to turn around and head straight back home. A year after the murders, Hal rode his motorbike to a long flat stretch of highway with no traffic. He accelerated until the speedometer reached 100 miles an hour. He then closed his eyes and took his hands off the handlebars. When Hal reopened his eyes, he was lying on the side of the road with his motorbike on the ground nearby. Hal was uninjured.
有一次，哈尔带着铲子开车去墓地，打算挖开她们的坟墓，只是为了确认她们真的在里面。他到达墓地后，却转过身直接开车回家。谋杀案发生一年后，哈尔骑着摩托车来到一段没有车辆的长直公路上。他加速直到时速表达到100英里。然后他闭上眼睛，双手离开了车把。当哈尔重新睁开眼睛时，他正躺在路边，摩托车倒在附近。哈尔没有受伤。
He took this as a sign that Joe, Michelle and Christie were watching over him and weren't ready for him to join them. Hal dusted himself off, got back on his bike and rode home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他把这视为一个信号，表明乔、米歇尔和克里斯蒂在守护着他，还没准备好让他加入她们。哈尔拍掉身上的灰尘，重新骑上摩托车骑回家。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。